It's an interesting thing to be at a place and to feel invested in that place...
...and then to have people outside come in and do such work.
And this is what Martin Luther King Day is about.
It's about getting into the community and helping...
...and everybody working together.
And this is a good example of Lancaster at work.
This really shows the commitment to service that is the spirit of Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
And it's always just a joy to see the people coming together and taking care of our community...
...and taking pride in our community.
It's been really a healthy thing, I think, to serve together, and it's through collaborative efforts like this...
...that things get accomplished...
...as different parts of our community come together with some leadership from our city.
And that is exactly what Dr. Martin Luther King would say or do.
He didn't pick color, he didn't pick religion, he didn't pick gender.
He just said, "Can I help?"